who do you think is more influential and
Powerful in Washington do you see the
lobbyists or the intelligence agencies
well I mean the answer to the question
is yes they're one and the same because
because often oftentimes they are fused
with precisely the same Personnel where
people will roll out of doj and end up
at you know the law firm that Services
the lobby Corps and and the very same
clients I mean there's no better example
of the fusion of that than when I
learned through a whistleblower that the
the Perkins cui Law Firm which is the
legal wing of the democratic party party
has within it a secure information
facility that is run by the FBI
so they literally have a place in their
Law Firm where they can try to convert
political dirt into intelligence
investigations counterintelligence
investigations criminal investigations
and the like yeah and let's not forget
all the epsteins it's up and running
today and they have all the Epstein
tapes too but that's another thing do
you have any hope in the Jim Jordan uh
new committee when it comes to
investigating the weaponization of
government do you think that's going to
be akin to maybe a church committee yeah
that that's our objective and the
specific agreement we have with McCarthy
is that that select committee will have
the budget Resources Personnel no less
than the Democrats January 6 committee
well what do you think do you think
it'll work out uh look it's hard to
promise outcomes when we don't have the
ability to throw handcuffs on anybody or
put anybody in jail right all we can do
is expose facts and so it relies on
other features of our system to kind of
go end to end on that accountability and
so I don't want to promise people like
yeah you know you're going to see Hunter
Biden hauled off in cuffs you're going
to see the Joe Biden University of Penn
like China money laundering stuff and
you know because
that may be out there but it may not
result in precisely what people would
hope upon upon encountering the
information and you want to ask about
you made that point about sometimes no
investigation that's better than
investigation oh yeah especially like
with the nist investigation for 9 11 I
mean there's so many holes in that thing
if you look at it objectively like I'm
concerned that
they would put forth an investigation
but it ends up being a sham and then
they're like okay we did it our
investigation's over everyone we didn't
find anything don't ask again as opposed
to no investigation and then this is the
Saudis Playbook right I mean you know
the Saudis were able to avoid the
responsibility uh that they have in the
911 attacks and in a terrorist attack in
my District in Pensacola
because they get a nice little report
written that you know sufficient to
absolve them and then they say oh well
not look not nothing to see here you
don't need to come back and conduct any
further inquiry do you fear or is that
concern when when creating Committees of
I don't know because I'm like well we
need an independent committee but who's
deciding who's on the independent
committee like how do you ensure that it
isn't a sham
Personnel I mean that that's why we know
that the people who will be on that
committee will be people like Jim Jordan
chip Roy Thomas Massey people actually
ask tough questions what is the point
what is the goal exactly like Are there
specific um directions that you guys are
aiming at thus far have you decided like
what what I don't know departments are
going to be investigated or what is our
specific things being looked for yeah
you heard McCarthy in his uh Speech
single out the FBI right he did not talk
about like a weaponized government in
the abstract when he spoke he spoke
specifically about politics at the FBI
so one of our first areas of inquiry is
going to be this Timothy t-ball guy who
suppressed information that was
derogatory to the bidens and did not
allow the normal process of criminal
inquiry to continue there and and they
do everything they can at the FBI to try
to supercharge anything that is really
to Trump or anyone around Trump or
anybody who's on the right and then if
it's the bidens they they function as
their Defender and they suppress the
derogatory information so that's
probably where we start I wonder how it
is that you know Trump being a wealthy
Elite and all that stuff still ends up
outside the big club that you know Joe
Biden seems to get away with everything
but Donald Trump is the target of
everything
do you think that it's it's a function
of elitism or do you think it's a
function of like Joe Biden just being of
the system right I mean he's all he is
of this place uh he chaired you know
foreign affairs in the Senate where you
interact with a lot of the people who
end up in powerful positions in the
intelligence community
and Trump went in with a goal of
reorganizing that and changing it and
that's I think why they kick back at him
so hard what I don't understand though
is if Trump or let's say Joe Biden is
part of the liberal economic order
that's you know we're evolving to a new
world order they say George Bush Senior
said that Klaus Schwab's intimated that
lots of people around the world aren't
realizing we're globalizing a new world
order it's not about American military
bases everywhere anymore now we're gonna
have a new type of thing but in that
instance I would think that the
Americans would want the Russians on
their side not siding with China and the
Chinese economic order I don't
understand why why are people pushing
Russia away if they're trying to create
a new world it's going to make them I'm
concerned it would make America number
three
well I mean what we're seeing right now
is the leverage buyout of Russia from
with a lot of Chinese cash I mean
they're they're more Chinese with two
million dollars cash in their bank
account right now like uh U.S uh
equivalent then there are total
Canadians
and so you know yeah you're you're
seeing uh a lot of the Farmland you know
in Russia uh get just bought out by the
Chinese and it it fuses those systems in
a way that poses a real substantial
threat to the United States to the West
at large are they buying our Farmland as
well yeah
I thought that maybe colonized maybe we
could propose some sort of peace deal
between Russia and Ukraine because the
what they're doing it looks like Putin's
trying to take a land bridge to Crimea
so that he has warm water access into
the Black Sea Russia basically after the
Soviet Union split up they they took it
all away from Russia and they gave
um they gave it to to Ukraine the city
what's the big city there right on the
right on the in Crimea and I think what
what we need to do is establish I don't
think Russia is ever going to stop until
they get a land bridge into Crimea in a
warm water Seaport so has that come up
in Congress you guys are like can we
I've got a pretty cynical view on the
you know Russia Ukraine conflict I uh
I've been voting against sending more
weapons there hold on let me get this
cough drop yeah dog I'll give you guys
well the geopolitical situation uh
especially yeah that's happening right
now and you're getting yeah a lot of
people in the comment section are saying
this is cough cast it's coffee uh
unfolding right now I think I'm the only
one I lost my voice meaning are the only
ones holding on here but it is a very
complex GOP political situation that I
think represents the larger proxy war
between the East and the West I think
sending in more weapons prolongs this
proxy conflict makes sure that of course
it goes on forever I think this war is
meant to be continued and not one
there's also a lot of debates now about
tanks uh to me do you think there's a
possibility for any kind of peace deal
because I think it's getting
um co-opted so many times including by
individuals like Boris Johnson that
literally go to Ukraine and say no
you're not going to even sit at the
table here with the Russians do you
think one year from now 10 years from
now there's some kind of possibility for
peace here or is this just going to be
who makes money on a previous deal
that's true yep right
I mean peace is not nearly as profitable
to those who
are in the war business you know it's
it's uh so obviously I don't have to say
it out loud I mean to me our involvement
in Ukraine is directly linked to our
diminished involvement in Afghanistan
like Afghanistan was the money
laundering capital of the world for like
a lot of our lifetime a lot of that cash
was like run through Dubai and you know
Abu Dhabi
and when that was not the corrupt
country that we just decided to pour
American Cash on like we needed another
historically corrupt country to go poor
American Military material and cash into
and gain a function research too Ukraine
fit the bill and so I don't believe that
like anyone's really working toward
peace I think that they're very powerful
interests that benefit if this is a
long-term low-yield War yes but CNN is
even reporting right now that the United
States is running low on some weapons
and ammunition because they're
transferring so much of it to Ukraine
right now so that's that's staggering
and also a dangerous for the United
States to be in such a vulnerable spot
as well so I I think you're absolutely
right there's a lot of bigger interest
here BlackRock just signed a deal with
Ukraine that they're going to be
rebuilding Ukraine as of course
BlackRock also has a lot of deals
funding uh and being a part of the
military-industrial complex that you see
the circle of life they're kind of
involving there is there any way to kind
of address this is there anything that
we could do as people to bring awareness
to this is there any way there could be
some kind of Peace here well the trend
lines are coming in my direction when it
comes to public perception on this I
mean initially like the American people
were dying to send every American dollar
you know to Ukraine and increasingly at
least within the Republican Party you've
started to see that shift as our
economic conditions are more in the
Forefront of people's minds like we have
laws that require end-to-end monitoring
of materiel when we send it into a war
zone and
I am not convinced We are following is
it because we're not technically at War
the United States hasn't been
technically at a war since World War II
well in a we do have regs that Define a
conflict Zone and whenever we send stuff
that kills into one of those places
we're supposed to know who has it thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time